been down this road before three
previous agreements fell in the House of
Commons I wonder have you had an
assurance from the Prime Minister that
he has the votes to get this one through
is it true that we have some experience
in this matter and why we use the
metaphor of mountaineering doesn't mean
that we're we there's no emotion here
but we have to be cautious as well I
have done my work our team has done
their work president Juncker has done
his part and afterwards the council in
Parliament will do their bit and the
House of Commons will have to take that
decision because it's their
responsibility I was a member of my own
national parliament and I know what that
responsibility means the decision taken
by referendum supported by the various
governments with whom we've been
negotiating means that we have fair and
reasonable agreement to use Boris
Johnson's own words and we have reached
that agreement together in full respect
it hasn't always been easy negotiations
have been complex what do you want me to
say I'm the EU chief negotiator
I never wanted even if I might say - to
give any judgement on British political
debate I fully respect those procedures
and the debate which has been a very
lively and interesting one but I
intended for us to suggest that